♪♪
Sea JUST LE WE HAVE
BEEN SHOWI ON THIS PROGRAM
NIGHT TER NIG, BDER
SECURITY, THAT IS NIONAL
SERITY, AND THEEVASTING
CONSEQUENCES O THE BID OPEN
BORDERS AGEN, THEY ARE
WORSENINGVERY DAY.
I MEAN, WE SE ANOER RECORD IN
MARCH BECAUSGET THI, FOX'S
OWN BL MEGIN HAS OBTAID A
NEW DOCUMT FROM CONESSMAN
IP R'S OFFE SHOWING A
REVEALING THERHASEEN 42 THEDEPAY
PEOPLE ON OUR TERR WATCH LIST
APPREHENDEAT THE BORDER SCEBIDE.
THAT ISN ADDITION TO THE 23RD
ALREADY KNEW ABOUT.
UNDER BID'S MASSIVE ENTRY
IMMIGRATIO POLICY FAILUS A
W MANY PEOE, BY THE WAY, GOT
THROUGH THAWE DN'T CATCH?
RROR AROUND THE WOR IS A
RE CLEAR PSENT DANGER, WEARE SOL
AROUND THELOBE, JUST DA AGO, ONH
SOALLEDSIS BEAESOUND
GUILTY ON ALL COUNT FOR HIS
MURDERERS OFOUR AMERICANSND
O BRITS, ILUDING AN AMERAN
D WORKER, CAL MUELL, AND
MEMBER, IT WASNDER
PRESIDENT TRP THI TERRORIST
ALLIES ERADITED TO TH U.S.
AN NOW JUSCE HAS BEE BROHT
THESE FAMILIES AND WE LL
VE MORE ON AT STRAIGHT AHD
BUT TONIG, O VER OWN
SA CARTER IS RORTING ONHE
STRANDED BY SMUGGRS, BEGGINGFORL
TA A LOOK.
I'M ON T PHONEITH A
FEMALEN DISTRES
SH HAS EYES O YOU.
SHE SS YOU ARE FLYG RIGHT
ABOVE HER
YOU HAVE ES O HER, AS WELL?>> I.
>> YES SIR, 1.
>>HE I FRO GUATEMA.
SHE WAS ABANDON AT THEOP OF
TH MOUAIN AND SHE I
TERRIED,HE I CRYING, SHESAID THH
HER.
BASICAY SD THEY WEREOING
TO CE BACK FOR HER AND THEY
NEVER DID THEY JUST ABDONE
HER UP OTHE MOUNTN.
ERE'S ALL KINDOF ELEMENTS
OU THERE, I MEA COME ON OUT
THER ALONE, SHEPENTHE NIGHT
OUT THERE, IT ULD HAVE DPPED
INTO T LOW 3, W KNOWS IF
SH WOULD HAVE MA IT.
E FACT WE EVEFOUN HER, YOU
KNOWTHATHE WAS ABLE T ME
WITH H PHONE FROM THE LAST
SECONDHE PNE BROKE,HAT SHE
S EVENBLE TOAKEHE PHONE
LL.
>> HGOES TO SHOWOU, WHATTHEY ARO
GARD FOR HUMAN LIFE.
THEY WILL LEA A PERSON BEHIND
D KEEP MOVING ON.
>> Sean:HAT' A SAD SRY.
OBVIOUY.
BUT YOUAVE, NOW,LL OF THESE
TERRISTS, ALL OF T FENNYL,
ALL OF THE OPIOIDS CING INTO
E COUNTRY, A OF O
MASSIVE SURGET THE BORR, A
NEW RECORD IN MAR OF THIS
YEAR, HIGHE THAN LT YEAR,
NOBODY SEEMS TO BE PAYING
ATTENTION  IT EXCEPT YOU AND
THIS SHO
AOT O PEOPLE HAVEGNORED IT
D JU GOTTEN USED T.
>> I'VE GOT TO TL YOU,
AN, IT IS EXTRAORDINILY
DANGOUS TIME.
YO TALO U.S. INTELLIGEE
AGENTSS WELL AS, YOUNOW,
OFFICERS, YOU SPEAK TO U.
MILITARY, UALK T O
FOIGN SERVICE AIESN
NTRAL AMERICA, THE WILL TEL
U THE SE THI, THEY ARE
EXAORDINARILY CONCERN ABOUT
THE TIONAL SECURITY AND
BASICALLY TOOREST BORR
HERE IN THE UNITED ATES BUREAU
I WANT TO SHOWOU BEHINDE,
SEAN, JUST A WE WERE GETTING
DISCOVERED A BY BEHIND M, THE
DY IS ON AN ISLAND, N TOO
FARROM ME DOWN T RIV.
WE HAVE XICAN AUTHORITIES AN
S. AUTHORITIESRYING TO
FIGURE OUT W IS GOINGO GET
THEODY OUT OF TH RIV.
THIS I SOMHING THAT HAPPS
DAILY.
DP
USEHE AIRCRAFT OPETIONS
DISION CONDUCTG TT RESCU
OFHE 1YEAR-OLD GL.
JUST LT WEEK, FOU A BY
OUTSID NOTOO FAR FROM WRE
TH YOUNG GL WAS RESCUED.
IT A CONSTT BATTL THE
SAY.
FEDERAL LAENFORCEMENT HERE AS
WELLS STE A LAL
LAW ENFORCENT ST TO SECURE
THIS BORDERND ITS ALMOS
IMPOSSIBLE TO SAYHEN THE BID
ADMISTRATION IS RUSINTO DO
IT
62,000LUS GOT AWAY JUST IN
MARC THAT TY KNO OF,ND
LISTENO THIS, SEA00,000,
THEY BIEVE, GOTWAY SINCE
OCBER 21.
THOSE ARE PEOE THAT WERE NOT
APPREHDED.
TH IS WHAT THEY ARE EIMATING
RIGHT NOW INHE FEDERAL
VERNMENT, AND THATS A VERY,VERYH
WHAT I